what's the deal with airplane peanuts
youel Rogan go comes up to me and goes I
want you to do my podcast and then I'm
like yeah he's like I'd really love you
whenever I go let's do it I still
haven't been on it why don't you follow
up with him follow well I'm I supposed
to text Joe and go hey can I be on I
don't want to so Joe was there with his
wife Saturday night he was driving away
from the store but he backs up he sees
me he goes what's up I go
hi and he goes so what why you
intimidated at me you know I I'm not
he's like you I I heard you you know
somebody gave me a clip or a couple
clips and he goes I love you you know
that right I think you're so funny and I
love you so much it just hasn't worked
out cuz I don't want the rejection so
it's like if I go right hey can I do it
and he goes H I don't know man I'm busy
man we know we got I got a lot I mean
maybe later you know I don't want that
if he said hey are you available
Thursday this day fly out do my podcast
I would 100% do it and that hasn't
happened yet
so interesting I have to mention I
mentioned to you before I'm a huge fan
of Bobby Lee he should be on this
podcast I love Bobby Lee I saw he was on
your show too yeah is I by the way Bobby
Le's been invited to do my podcast
multiple times I'm going to have to
reach out to him I feel like he is so I
might have to fly to LA and hold his
hand and drag him on a flight I bet sh
could get you in all right Bobby Lee is
quite possibly the most requested Joe
Rogan guest of all time well known today
as one of the internet's most popular
comedians Bobby Lee has been a guest on
almost every major podcast known to man
except one the SLP king's name being
absent from The Joe Rogan guest list has
been driving comedy fans crazy for years
even causing some to believe that there
might secretly be bad blood between the
two I made it I'm here and it's just
like what a blessing no just let me let
me finish this what a blessing over the
years people on the internet were like
why don't you do Rogan I was like I
don't even know how and I'm here now and
I just feel so present and I feel
mindful it's is going to be a great one
anyway thanks for having here you too
man yeah we talked about doing it a
thousand times thousand times yeah and
it never happened people thought they
like we had a problem with each other or
something no we know in fact here's the
deal Joe okay Bobby not only do we not
have a problem with each other right
you've been a very really big asset to
me over the years I love you so we're
the opposite of trouble we're in a like
family yes that's how I feel the story
of Joe Rogan and Bobby League goes back
many decades starting with their time
spent coming up together in the LA
comedy scene during the mid99s as some
people know Bobby Lee technically has
been a guest on The Joe Rogan Experience
before way back on episode number 76
when the show was filmed on Joe's couch
and long before it was even remotely
considered to be a big deal ladies and
gentlemen Bobby Lee has joined us but
the reason that Bobby Lee has not
returned to the show in over 11 years
has always been a topic of conversation
amongst comedy fans online as well as
comedi iians themselves Bobby Lee's
relationship with Joe Rogan seems
somewhat complicated from an outsider's
point of view only hearing the anxious
stories Bobby tells about Joe on
tigerbelly even though Joe Rogan has
always maintained a deep admiration and
respect for Bobby Lee publicly and
apparently has also always been helpful
to Bob behind the scenes sometimes they
go to The Comedy Store yeah Joe Rogan
really hates me and like it's based on
nothing nothing it's just some sort of
in my head building up scenarios that
don't really even exist and I go through
these torturous you know moments in bed
where I'm laying there and I and I go
into this like you know and I just want
to stop doing that Rog goes comes up to
me and goes I want you to do my podcast
yeah and then I'm like yeah he's like
I'd really love you whenever I go let's
do it okay and still haven't been on it
why don't you follow up with him I'm I
supposed to text Joe and go hey can I be
on I don't want to why why because asked
you I'm curious about yeah because I'll
tell you why okay is is that people that
do our podcast I ask them people ask
yeah and then they follow up like not
through me um I feel like I feel like
Joe you know I've known Joe for 20 years
yeah I love Joe Rogan he's the best MH
okay but there is he's an alpha male
okay and I'm a coward I I literally am
weak and I'm a I'm a follower the
tension felt by Bobby Lee seemed to be
caused not only by Joe's Macho
personality an intimidatingly large
platform but also may stem from past
interactions with Joe Rogan that
constantly Replay in Bobby's head
specifically an incident that took place
at The Comedy Store almost 20 years ago
related to Joe Rogan calling out Carlos
Mania and the following aftermath that
included Brian Redban releasing a video
of Bobby Lee admitting that Carlos stole
Jokes which in turn caused a load of
issues between Bobby and his then Mentor
Ned but he also you know I was
associated with menia back in the day
because the video that came up because I
used to open for Mia a lot during that
time it was very uncomfortable with me
and Rogan and that group of guys you
know red band and whoever and so I kind
of built from the ground up a
relationship with them over [__] 15
years and now I feel like I've gained
the respect of you know Comics what and
whatnot redband releasing the Bobby
video was Major drama at the time
because of the terrible position it
pinned Bobby in between Mania and Rogan
but Bobby did speak directly into a
camera so it's kind of hard to really
blame Red Band for that one there are
countless more stories that Bobby has
told about Minor interactions with Joe
Rogan that undoubtedly play into Bobby's
builtup angst including jokes made about
Bobby's high school wrestling background
but Joe Rogan yes one time came to when
he lived in La this is years ago he said
you're a liar you've never grappled yeah
and I go yes I did you you're a [__]
liar no you didn't and at that time I
didn't have any photos to prove it but
if you look at my Instagram I have
photos as well as one of the first Times
Bobby Lee went up at The Comedy Store
men goes hey dude you come up and do you
know come to La bro so I went up there
on a Saturday night and mity saw me
there and I was hanging out with Carlos
in the main room green room and Carlos
goes hey mity put him up right you're a
new comic I'm new yeah and MIT goes yeah
you go up and Joe roken says Joe Rogan's
there and Joe Rogan goes mity he's from
[__] San Diego he's not funny or
something like that he's not [__]
funny right yeah he'll be fine that's
what she said I went up there not only
did I not hear any laughs I hear Rogan
in the back going I [__] told you
he's not funny he's not [__] funny
M's from the but despite these old
stories Joe Rogan has always made it
clear that he not only loves Bobby Lee
but that he's welcome on the show
literally any time which is something
bobb's known for years now but for some
reason has never acted on so Joe was
there with his wife Saturday night and
he was driving away from the store but
then he backs up he sees me he gets out
of this car he goes what's that [__] I
go
hi so I go hi and he goes so what why
are you intimidated at me I go I'm not
so bad what I'm not beef no I go you
know I I'm not he's like you I I heard
you you know somebody gave me a clip or
a couple clips and he goes I love you
you know that right I [__] think
you're so funny and I love you so much
and then you know what I realized what
it was it's a Korean thing and I'm going
to say this I think that's what it is
because in the Korean culture your
elders you have to respect them when I
respect somebody like that I don't I
want to be intrusive cuz I when to he he
shows up Comics just crowd around him
right and he plays you know and I I just
don't I say hi a hug I get out you know
by him saying that was so gracious it
really was really gracious he's like I
want you on the show when can you do it
this and that so I'm going to do it and
um I'm now really confident about doing
it I think I know now that I can do it
another reason Bobby Lee historically
provided for not going on J was simply
that he's been waiting for something
extra special to promote I I want to use
it for like a real important thing like
you know if I have something really big
to promote and I'm really you know what
I mean I bet sh could get you in all
right which is a theory that he even
explained to Joe in this next clip while
also soft launching some pretty big news
that it's quite honestly the main
talking point of this entire episode
you're very good comment yeah and I I
also want to tell you the reason why I
didn't want to do this now is because
I'm doing a special and I want to
promote it okay and I thought maybe I
could only do it once every 5 years but
then your people said that I could do it
when I you could do this anytime you
want okay yeah yeah yeah yeah I feel I
feel that now you have my number I'm
going to call you I'm going to text you
I'm going to I'm going to do want I it's
going to be great listen I love you I'm
I love you
to if you thought the internet went
crazy for Bobby Lee's first Rogan
episode just wait till his debut standup
special drops his fans have been waiting
for a special for decades now and it's
going to be interesting to see which
streaming platform buys this project or
if it gets released on YouTube as well
as the actual jokes themselves and all
the podcast promotion that comes with
releasing a special Bobby leaves on the
verge of reaching all new heights in his
standup career with the release of a
killer hour although there is an
argument for his current mysterious
approach of making the people come see
you live there's no Legacy yes there
there is no Legacy look let me see
something who is one of the best Comics
that died in the last 10 years Patrice
right yeah none of the kids know him
that's not true that's not true they
don't well if you if you have no hours
out maybe there's no Legacy uhoh that's
a shot oh no why didn't you look at me
when why didn't you look at me when you
said it look at him can I tell you that
I noticed that too yeah why did you look
at him took the shot you took the shot
look at me and say it yeah take the shot
if you're going to take the shot too
take the shot you're going to shoot a
guy in the back yeah yeah yeah that's
what you no you go go ahead you know
what he did dude he sucker punched you
yeah he walked up to me he looked at you
boom and punched you without even just
say it you [__] go ahead no I was
just saying the Legacy thing you know
that you have to put
bro bro bro I love how R's getting go
ahead yeah go ahead slow down you have
to put something out there to get a leg
okay I know what I'm saying though is is
that I know so many great Comics that
have died right sure no Legacy okay but
what he's saying is if you built up if
you built up something no one has it in
this day and age there's in 100 years
future people are going to go oh look at
um Caligula by Anthony jezl neck they're
not going to say that someone might one
guy who gives a [__] you're dead no but
he's not saying it for himself saying
sake of take the Legacy thing out yeah
as a fans of yours yeah if you come see
me live but that's the Jay lenov Theory
that's what he said come see me live
He's not going to put out hours because
he says just come see me live until I
don't do it anymore really that's his
whole thing he did an interview with
rolling stone or something like that
where he kind they were saying how come
you don't put out specials like everyone
in your generation is doing now like
Romano put out one and he was like just
come see me
it is pretty rare nowadays for a
comedian this established and famous to
be making their first modern day Rogan
appearance which is really a testament
to Bobby for becoming this large in the
podcast space without ever truly
receiving the Rogan bump that most of
the dominant podcasters and Comics have
experienced at one point or another
going on a podcast that averages 190
million audio downloads per month paired
with 16 million YouTube subscribers has
to give even Bobby Lee a huge boost in
exposure overall this episode was was
everything you'd expect it to be with
topics ranging from old comedy stories
from back in the day to Joe Rogan trying
to sell Bobby on Austin Texas you have
to understand what you guys did what did
we do you guys took half of the talent
out so I was just butt hurt we brought
another bunch in too like Shane Gillis
lives here I know I know he does doing
great I know you guys are killing it I
went to the club last night come move
here I know you're more than Paulie's
thinking about it Paulie's here a lot I
know PA was just here the Theo's
thinking right yeah they're all just
worried that like people go oh you move
there suck on Rogan's nuts I would never
suck your nuts I don't ask I wouldn't do
it if you did it would be a problem yeah
I'd be like why are you doing this I'd
have to be asleep would you hurt me no
if you okay we weren't camping if I woke
up and you were sucking my it wouldn't
hurt you what I would yell at you would
hurt you yeah be like what the [__] dude
that felt good I was in the middle of a
dream what if I was in the middle of a
sex and you suck my be so mindful too
bro that would be a real problem for the
rest of my life the hardest I ever
came I would I was sleeping yeah I would
sex dream and Bobby Lee was sucking my
nuts I don't know why he was doing it it
was just for fun he didn't know I've
suck nuts before but like you know I get
it yeah but um yeah I'm me and Santina
will maybe think talk about it Bobby
also made an appearance at the comedy
Mothership while he was in town coming
out to a room full of excited fans so
it'll be interesting to see if bad
friends moving to Austin has any legs or
not let me know in the comments what you
think about Bobby Lee potentially moving
to Texas please consider subscribing to
joke world right now if you enjoyed this
recap and be sure to check out the end
screen right after this to find more
videos related to all your favorite
comedians thanks for
watching joke
World let it J
world and it world is wld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out